trip has been a trip um are you helping
write for kanye or something
um i don't know
um but i want to make a lot of music
this year was that a nice like shot in
the dark that might be accurate no okay
i just gotta ask because i feel like
every time someone comes to la they end
up writing for kanye west randomly in a
studio session it's like oh [__] so
you're writing for yay that's big that's
big donda two bars down to two bars huh
hey so when kanye reached out to you man
like did he dm you or did he like did he
get in touch with him so much music this
year it's gonna be so good
knowing yay changed your life what's it
like working with him
i do love yay's music have you met let
me just ask you this have you ever met
kanye west that's a fair question right
without revealing anything have you ever
met the guy
yes
and is he in was he nice yeah did you
meet him recently
dude i'm so
everything i'm gonna make so much music
it's gonna be so good